schon mal die karten
schön wär schon was zu trinken für sie
ein bisschen wein zum essen vielleicht
ich hätte gerne einen riesling dass er
40 oder wie beim beispiel wäre es ein
bisschen milder fruchtig dann nehme ich
den weißburgunder und für sie auch ein
glas wein pro sie vielleicht zum
hauptgang
ich nehme lieber ein bier alles klar
[Musik]
schön ich für sie den preis wunder denn
gerne mal ausprobieren
ja
haben sie schon entschieden dass sie
essen möchten ja ja ja das dürfen wir
ihnen bringen
für mich gerne die berater die wird ohne
nüsse zubereitet ja wir können müssen
das dressing ändern weil öl drin ist
aber dass kein problem das kriegen wir
hin
für sie mich bitte die gurken joghurt
wir wollten ja gerne bei ihnen auch
irgendwas worauf achten müssen irgendwas
was sie nicht vertragen und im hauptgang
was nachrichten damit bringen
für mich ich hätte als hauptgang gerne
den kalbsrücken ja mit pfifferlingen und
den kalbsrücken gerne rosa tobias machen
wir ja gern alles klar